i mean i wanted to be able to answer any
of the questions that you may have had
based on the plan that we submitted for
consideration
to the board on tuesday
so i'll start with you all say my voice
so uh the question is did the county
expect to be at
a hundred percent june 1st here's what i
would tell you
we've been doing yeoman's work in clark
county
well over 700 000 first doses
and i think that we can absolutely get
there
as long as people continue to get
vaccinated
and get tested to ensure that it's not
spreading within our community
what are what are the steps you're
taking in between
so um so the question is what milestones
are we taking to
be on track for june 1st is that
basically what you're saying so
we've been doing that uh since we opened
vaccines
in december because we know how
important it is to
keep in our community safe as well as
the economic driver
to get our community back on track so
each and every day
we work across the valley we have
several partners
that we work with from north las vegas
henderson
mesquite boulder city not counting our
private sector
partners with the pharmacies to ensure
that we can get vaccines
out and make them accommodate
accommodate
for everyone we track every single day
the positivity rate
uh we track it over seven days over 14
days
we monitor our sewer systems so
we've been doing that for a little over
13
months and we'll continue to do that and
all indicators show
that we can definitely start opening our
community back up
in a short timeframe
you're i'm sure um heard from
constituents a lot over the last 13
months everyone has an opinion on
uh lockdowns whether they choose to
accomplish or not
what kind of feedback are you getting
from constituents from your constituents
as far as
is this something that they were
expecting
sooner is it later is there still fear
out there among the community we might
be moving too fast
so good thing is i haven't heard from
any constituents since five o'clock last
night
but i have been a little bit under the
weather myself so
what i can tell you we're calling in
every single day
across the valley to ask people if
they've had their
vaccine if they want to get their
vaccine there are many businesses
that haven't been open then i'm excited
to
get them open so for instance
the folks that run the pool the pool
and arcade games in our local taverns
uh they're in our plan to reopen them
we think we can do it safely uh adult
entertainment
is also in the plan to reopen uh karaoke
recently reopened
buffets which are a big part of who we
are
in clark county those will be able to
open
and i think that people will be
excited to have those venues i think
that businesses
will be excited to be back open and and
that's really we want to
go in a positive direction and then as
far as
the other commissioners are concerned
i'm sure
feel about you know the timelines that
you've laid out
so here's what i would tell you we work
through a regional
multi-agency committee which is
comprised of all of the cities across
the valley
as well as our airport our hospital
so we work through that committee
through business size and
business licensing and so that community
created the plan which includes the
chamber which includes the resort
association
and so it will be presented to the board
for public discussion
on tuesday and so i have not talked to
any of the commissioners about it in
particular
um because we do have to follow open
meeting law but there's a regional
committee that works together
to make that determination um looking at
the local plan
starting on may 1st social distancing
rules
still apply but there's also language in
there that talks about
unless there is
so here's what i would tell you um we
will go back through our
uh this this weekend uh the board will
discuss it
on tuesday there we have to see what
other
things may need to be changed based on
the conversation that was had yesterday
so
it will be up to the board on tuesday to
have those discussions
so currently they are still going
through the bni
process bni has been working
directly with the clark county health
district
um they have offered some additional
mitigation
efforts and i don't know where those
plans are today
uh but everybody is you know in our
town we have to plan three months six
months in advance
so that we can get on track and so
i specifically haven't talked to any
sports teams at all but i do know that
the health district
and b and i are working together to
address some of those issues
here's what it will tell you every day
is a concern right because it's always
changing and my job is to ensure that
our community is safe
uh first and foremost and that is what
we've done
all along is put public health first
however we also need to
weigh all the impacts
from you know businesses that have
need to get back on track the mental
health
capacity for folks and the unemployment
all of that weighs on a person in many
ways so
what i'll tell you is we'll continue to
put public health first
and then we will um we'll we will work
to
open as we need and we'll constantly be
reevaluating
after june 1st we won't go away
we'll still have to evaluate it we'll
still be giving vaccines at that point
so public health is our top priority
uh here's what i will tell you we won't
uh we won't cut back
we'll continue to make our efforts we
have done
a yeoman's job across the valley
every single week with our enforcement
education pieces and anytime you
start to change things you have to
re-educate folks on
what that looks like so we'll continue
all of those measures
as we have done in the past
so i don't believe that the plans will
deviate
differently from the state and the
county we work very closely with bni
we've had to work with bni this entire
time and
pretty good relationships i know that
they're constantly
working to ensure that at the end of the
day that the enforcement can be handled
and that public health is a priority so
i don't anticipate
folks have the ability to put in their
plans
up to april 30th through a june 30th
approval and we've worked hand in hand
with bni
through that process
i've personally spoken with them and
what i can tell you is i said
that you know we have encouraged people
to have
vaccine areas or a negative pcr and that
is something that
we have spoken about since last november
they also said that they would like
public health to be a priority because
that is
the social priorities of the groups that
go there so
that was my only conversations and
they've been working directly with bni
and the health district as late as
yesterday
i feel that we can do a lot of things
safely if we all
you know set out priorities and we work
together
to enforce uh the very rules that we lay
out for each other
um you can do tons of things safely
so it'll be entirely up to the venue for
them to decide
if they like the limit capacities and if
they can
adhere to the rules set forth by the
health district
okay one more question my voice is
so what i would tell you i will wear my
hat
as the chairperson of naco which is all
of the counties across the state
and for the most part everybody is
working together
to ensure that each county
based on their needs can get going so
for instance story county has
not had very many positives this entire
time
lincoln county has not so they likely
could
open to a hundred percent much faster
but remember that clark county is the
engine
that drives uh the train economically
we're also the engine that is
has the highest unemployment rate so we
do not
want to shut back down so we need a
measured approach
so that we can continue to stay on top
of it and
what i'll tell you to elaborate a little
bit farther
we have done a great job in clark county
so a lot of people
have worked we have beat every
obstacle that has been in our way we
barriers
in the beginning to where fema
came in last july 24th and said that we
could be overrun
we continue to stay measured we continue
to work collaboratively and we will um
we will be more successful that way
okay thank you all for coming sorry to
keep you waiting
and until tomorrow
thank you